[Music]
in heroin hero news submitted by Stephen
Chow a liar a desperate father did the
unthinkable in order to help his heroin
addicted son get clean what'd he do beat
a son unpredictable maybe he did heroin
I think what happened is the son was
like [ __ ] up like this Oh heroin and
if dad's gonna speak to him logically
but it's not getting into his brain so
he's like how do I connect with him on
the same wavelength it was like and then
in this heroin world this son's like you
know like wouldn't wanders like a guy
that's high on meat yeah you can't
really talk to the sober person yeah
they know they're not the same lately
yeah but once you have two guys that are
faded now they can talk about
metaphysics and even though none of them
know anything about physics yeah but it
makes sense they're talking about space
and [ __ ] that sounds more real actually
show a TV show where like the mom was a
heroin addict and so the son shut up in
front of the mom when she was sorry
about I mean like look at what it does
to you kind of thing did it work with
now the most conventional TV show oh I
was just thinking I was just thinking
that the dad signed him both up for an
amateur fight and they both got into a
fight in a cage that's thinkable also
the dad could beat the son's ass
legally yeah and say this is what
happens when you do hero it or it could
be more simple like he took a dump in
his grandma's mouth that's more
complicated actually
oh just to show them like if you're on
heroin you do crazy [ __ ] I forgot the
plan okay No
I get dragged into this not least the
dentures come out really clean he just
[ __ ] left you stranded you want too
far you lost me at dentures man the
pooping in the mouth is okay but the
dentures man the dentures I just
pictured [ __ ] soft-serve well Bart
you're right did shoot up heroin oh well
that was my idea
sorry do you think your you guys both on
it okay we'll split the trophy in a few
yeah I totally forgot about Geo he
always gets the credit for everything
anyone you can keep the whole trophy dad
his name is Sergey he's 45 years old
they live in New York
oh uh so his son Michael he's 23 years
old he his son has been using heroin
ever since he was 15
oh it's one of those drugs like I said I
don't know anyone I did a lot of drugs
and i just don't know anyone that did
heroin maybe it's not a California thing
maybe it's like my shadows there's New
York Oh New York I forgot that part
jack is a surgery yeah yeah somebody
tell me which scene does heroin like is
it the punk rock scene like is it the
goth scene like what is it oh I don't
think there's a scene it's so hardcore
yeah I feel like I don't know the way
I've been reading a lot of these reports
on the media and the fact that there's
like this heroin epidemic it seems like
heroin it's like
than you like Coke or something like
everyone really is there heroin in
Hawaii is their epidemic I know that
there's a meth epidemic out there cuz i
was thinkin maybe heroin is I could end
Dorothy you know like wrestling like the
the states where it gets hella cold
they're really good at wrestling because
you can't really play football play
basketball so those states the kids they
stay indoors and do wrestling right and
I think like on West Coast at California
there's so much beautiful weather people
that are out of smoke we and they can go
outside and relax but it's the places
that are held a cold they don't have
anything to do and they got to go inside
maybe heroines are inside thing oh I
don't know anybody that does a heroine
and I don't know what cult like what
subculture is like cuz it's like alright
when you think of we what do you think
reggae you think a little bit of hip hop
maybe a little bit of rock and roll
that's true when you think of coke what
do you think like maybe a little you
know like party scene Beverly Hills
right what do you think of ecstasy
festivals raves right what do you think
of meth trailer-trash and grant ask ina
people yeah so every drug has it when I
think of heroin I just think dudes under
a bridge with a burning trash can
sharing a needle and getting AIDS that's
what I think yeah we to my mind goes
there but like I'm saying it seems like
it's so common now like a lot of people
are doing it which is not just niche
like that word yeah I've been too long
away from a drug scene where I'm just
not hip to the ku I don't understand
anymore
really I lost touch maybe I got to get
back
yes I could report back hey guys just
found out circles hey guys no it's not a
not a bum thing I just found out no
we'll go to forums don't worry just
chill out
yeah so what this dad did is he his son
told him he was gonna be going into
rehab then he found more drugs in the
home he was so upset he's like you know
what I don't know what else to do like
I'm willing to go above and beyond for
my son like I'm willing to lose
everything to not lose him so he ended
up taking the drug and we started
overdosing oh no son he watched his
daddy overdose he recognized that his
his dad was overdosing because he
watched sure he started doing CPR on him
and who used this nasal spray to bring
him back from overdosing so she was able
to save his dad in that aspect and then
maybe like he was saying like but like
pop-pop
are you crazy you're almost died within
the Dead like you know what like if I
lose you I don't know look at what you
made me do I'll give you my home my car
my heart I don't want to lose you drugs
and [ __ ] and I book that's a tough dad
though I I'd actually be too scared to
do heroin I rather beat up my son yeah I
mean I'm like I'm so scared of doing
heroin I don't know why shrooms and
heroin I always stayed away from those
two things cuz I was just [ __ ] scared
of them from all the stories so he did
it without his son even being in the
room he was like [ __ ] it I'm gonna [ __ ]
up let me experiment like that's the way
it was why I think if I wanted to do
that in that like wanted to take the
route he did I would do it in front of
my son like watch this [ __ ]
either that or like [ __ ] you let's just
do it together let's see what the [ __ ]
happens what you like he was in the home
you can he was trying to prove a point
or he just wanted to feel what it was
like that his sons going through you
know you're trying to prove prove a
point
like he's trying to to prove to his son
like this she's not bar I have to go to
get you to stop doing this how did he
know how to prepare himself is it
already bad probably why she overdose
because he didn't know how much to take
so he was just like [ __ ] alright
whatever yeah and this is the son the
only moto I could find oh yeah
I like how the photographer was like hey
can you just pretend like you're arguing
right now why you want smirk yeah like I
want it dramatic it's like these
photographers that report this stuff
like the journalism and stuff they
couldn't be like Instagram photographers
or print so then they try to flex their
art inside this and find like a dramatic
scene yeah but when people see it they
don't see the back story so they look at
and they go oh my god there's so much
emotion in this picture like how sad but
all I see is like him setting it up can
you pretend like you're like fighting
again but yeah just can you just smoke
that cigarette like I don't give a [ __ ]
and then like yeah you know what let's
get more trash on this table
make it look junky come on the article
it seemed like and I don't even know how
they got in contact with with this son
and and his dad but after email me you
know I don't even know how like they
even found out about them but it seems
like this entire article was written
when they were in their home cuz they're
writing it like you know as he had a
single tear in his eye he's telling him
this meaning loser dude in the corner
with a laptop because it's so there's a
photographer and a personal laptop in
that room just as he slowly reaches for
the lighter his dad is lecturing him and
he is saying anything for you my son
I've been fortunate enough to not have
to like anyone with your mom the heroin
my mom and like witness anyone that's
really close to me good
that is so scary [ __ ] my arm seen it a
couple of times a couple that I only
know one time well that's the craziest
one another one is one of our well I
think it's the same guy but we had to
carry him out of the club
same dude yeah he's like doing these
like overdosing everywhere help him out
I think he's uh I think he likes it
yeah it's like a prerequisite to his
live now yeah he's actually a highly
intelligent he's getting his master's
right now right I think HD actually oh
[ __ ] he's a researcher yeah but I I have
this thing where like I believe that
people that are highly intelligent they
require a lot of stimulus for them to
feel anything so like for him he had
this high as tolerance of stuff for what
when he would do drugs you would have to
do a whole bunch of [ __ ] yeah just
wouldn't feel anything yeah but after
time I think everybody will Bob build a
tolerance like to alcohol or whatever
but for him it was just always insane
amounts to the point where like you can
die doing that yeah whenever I did
anything like I always just did the
recreational [ __ ] like the bare basic
stuff um but I never wanted to mix
anything cuz I was just so scared like I
wanted to still be semi-coherent
to like the [ __ ] I was doing so it was
like if I smoked out that's all I'm
doing just smoking out like I'm not
trying to get drunk and I always wanted
to be completely let go and obliterate
it where like if I lose control I don't
know what's gonna happen hopefully I
wake up somewhere strange scary I mean I
mixed [ __ ] like like a kid does at a
soda machine what was your thought
process because his is he just I think
when you're 14 or 15 you don't have this
idea of you can die oh so like it's kind
of like you and then you also feel like
so good right so you're going you're all
one thing and then you mix another thing
and you're like look this is crazier
than the last time and then nothing is
as good as your first time yeah so then
you do another that you add you know I'm
coming down from IE high so imma [ __ ]
take a hit of weed and then you know
what I never did acid before so let me
get a gel
have and let me get on this [ __ ] and
then someone has a prescription drug and
you do that and before you know it it
was midnight but now it's 7:00 a.m. and
you're driving in circles inside of
maybe that you don't know and the whole
world is [ __ ] now someone else is
driving there probably under the
influence - and I'm just looking at the
same houses over and over and it feels
like for one hour I just been doing this
passing the same house over and over and
in like a part of you is like I want to
get normal again
but I don't know when I'm getting out of
this portal the best normal is fun [ __ ]
this dude yeah like when you get [ __ ]
up and you get as normal as positive
we'd you back to life you get the hot
[ __ ]
and you put hella lemons in it oh yeah
that was the best I know crazy I'm
surprised you guys are alive I know
thank you for any acts don't do drugs
don't do it hope you guys enjoyed that
video if you did a really cool way to
communicate that to us and for you to
never miss another video is by
subscribing so click on that little
subscribe button and you'll never miss
an episode for the next episode click
right up here
[Music]